الاقتراب الأخير لطائرة مقاتلة شبحية من طراز f-35c
قبل ثوانٍ من تحطمها
وهبطت في سطح الطائرة لصور
حاملة طائرات أمريكية تم
تداولها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وأكدتها البحرية الأمريكية تظهر الطائرة
بعد لحظات في مظلة المحيط المفتوحة
بعد أن هرب طيارها
سبب التحطم الذي أصاب
الطيار وستة بحارة ما زالوا قيد
التحقيق ،
فإن البحرية الآن لديها مهمة صعبة تتمثل في
استعادة حطام طائرة 100 مليون
دولار من قاع المحيط
للتأكد من أن خبراء الدفاع يقولون أن
تقنيتها السرية لا تفعل ذلك.  الوقوع
في الأيدي الخطأ
للصينيين تاريخ طويل في القدرة على
استعارة شيء ما من الخارج
وهندسته العكسية بحيث يكون هذا
بالتأكيد منجم ذهب بقدر ما
يحدث ، حدث الانهيار هنا في
بحر الصين الجنوبي بشكل كبير  المسطح
المائي الذي تم تهريبه والذي تطالب به بكين
تقريبًا بنفسها وهذا هو المكان الذي تعمل فيه
حاملتا طائرات أمريكيتان
حاليًا برفقة أكثر من 10  0
طائرات حربية وما لا يقل عن 10 سفن حربية أخرى
دليل واضح على
القوة البحرية الأمريكية لكل من الحلفاء والمنافسين في
آسيا ، هناك تذكير قوي بأن
كون المحيط الهادئ يمثل
أهمية إستراتيجية مركزية لإدارة توزيع الأرباح ،
فهو يتعلق بإرسال إشارات إلى
المنافسين الآخرين في المنطقة
وأبرزها الصين أن مصداقية الولايات المتحدة
لا ينبغي الاستخفاف
بها ، وتقول وزارة الخارجية الصينية إنها
غير مهتمة بالطائرة المحطمة ،
حث المتحدث الولايات المتحدة على المساهمة بشكل
أكبر في السلام الإقليمي بدلاً من
استعراض القوة في كل منعطف ، لكن
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية فعلت بعض الشماتة  القول بأن
الحادث كشف عن إجهادنا
لاحتواء الصين
، فهذه ليست المرة الأولى التي تتعرض فيها البحرية
الأمريكية لحادث بينما تؤكد ما
تقوله واشنطن أنه حقها في إجراء
عمليات بحرية للملاحة في
هذه المياه المتنازع عليها
في أكتوبر الماضي ، تحطمت غواصة هجومية تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية
في أعماق البحر.  دفع جبل في
بحر الصين الجنوبي إلى
إطلاق قوافله  وفي الوقت نفسه ، فإن الطائرة
الحربية متعددة الاستخدامات من طراز F-35 التي طورت سنوات
متأخرة عن الجدول الزمني وبطريقة تجاوزت الميزانية
قد تعرضت لانتكاسات خاصة بها في الآونة الأخيرة
، حيث تحطمت طائرة F-35 بريطانية في البحر الأبيض المتوسط
وفمبر في عام 2019 ، تحطمت طائرة يابانية من طراز F-35 في
لمحيط الهادئ مما أسفر عن
قتل  طيار الطائرة التي تأثرت بسرعة عالية
لدرجة أن فرق الإنقاذ لم تسترد أبدًا
معظم الطائرات التي كانت تحلق من
حاملات الطائرات هي عمل محفوف بالمخاطر
، وستحدث أحيانًا مشاكل
بينما من المؤسف أنه
من المتوقع أن تبدأ في الطيران
بمئات الطلعات الجوية التي يتوقعها
الخبراء.  سيستغرق
البحرية الأمريكية عدة أسابيع لاستعادة هذا
الحطام الباهظ الثمن من قاع
البحر إيفان واتسون CNN hong kong